the last 12 to 24 months we're talking
I'm the best Freddie Gibbs we're talking
killer Mike Royce and then there's the
Grizelda squad I'm talking for the Gibbs
but what I wanted to talk to you about
okay
okay yesterday Lambo tweeted what he
tweeted where's the two days ago correct
yeah he did so Lambo essentially was
like yo when was the last time a rapper
job two projects yes sir as amazing as
alfredo in bandana mm-hmm and
back-to-back years now in my head I
thought to myself do you mix it's dark
and hell is hot right the same thing I
thought my flesh of my flesh blood of my
blood now like like West Side gun is my
boy like like and listen like yo I am a
huge result of fan and I am a I I think
that what they've done is special and I
think that they're like when we're
having the discussion mm-hmm of like the
good guys in rap and they'll eat in
hip-hop like those guys are in the
discussion that you mentioned Benny the
butcher being one of your your you know
a dear friend of mine um and I think I
think on wait dear friend the money what
what your thoughts on what Westside gun
said because he's obviously put out a an
an amazing amount of work mm-hmm
and and I told you this before we
started the pocket I was like he'll pray
for Paris is one of my top 5 ounces
right when you saw that tweet I think
that it was in jest obviously but like
you know these got I think Westside gun
comes from a place for like for so long
they didn't get any love or recognition
have you talked to him yeah he knows
what's up you know so fam so get back to
doing get back to your regularly
scheduled program because it's Casey's
listen I think I think gun is you know
he's that he's the Suge he is the huh
Dame - behind
he's the mind behind result of course of
crises and I see as though he's a genius
I'll give him that
the branding all that like like Westside
gun is like love we got to give him
props I love risotto I love and that's
what I want to get to that's all of pray
for Paris we agreed it's a gray area I
pray what were you that's a great album
you're on the [ __ ] it's a greater
foots a great [ __ ] down by the way
don't get that [ __ ] go stream this keep
it going shout The Alchemist I just want
to see a world in which Freddie Gibbs
and grizelda aren't cool I'm cool
Grizelda shot West Side gonna drop -
Bennie Shopatron extreme all of this
[ __ ] go get all that [ __ ] buy all of
this